Yeah, just for everybody's benefit, we are always on camera when we do this, and I have just been wearing my bathrobe because I just came out of the shower and did my hair. You're going to cut that out. You're going to cut that out. All right. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 50 recorded on November 5th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about the great Twitter war between Bryce and JF. Here's what happened, folks.
对啦，为了大家好，我们录节目时都是开着摄像头的，我刚才一直穿着浴袍，因为我刚洗完澡，还吹了头发。这段你会剪掉的。这段你会剪掉的。好吧。欢迎来到第50期 ADSP 播客节目，录制于2021年11月5日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）将聊聊布莱斯和 JF 之间旷日持久的推特大战。各位，事情是这样的。
Well, not folks. Here's what happened, folk. Oh, shoot. You can't say. There's no singular of folks. Here's what happened, folks. Not folks. Here's what happened, folk. Oh, shoot. You can't say. There's no singular of folks. Here's what happened, listener. Yeah, because folk is a plural, too. Folk is like the people. Is it? The folk.
好吧，不是各位（folks）。事情是这样的，各位（folk）。哦，糟了。你不能说……没有 folks 的单数形式。事情是这样的，各位（folks）。不是 folks。事情是这样的，各位（folk）。哦，糟了。你不能说……没有 folks 的单数形式。事情是这样的，听众。对，因为 folk 也是个复数。Folk 就像是人们。是吗？这群人。
Yeah. The listener. We recorded. This is definitely the most last-minute recording. In fact, this is like post-last-minute. We could have done this live. the most last minute recording. In fact, this is like post last minute. We are now... We could have done this live. I mean, yeah, usually at this point,
对。听众朋友。我们录制……这绝对是史上最临时起意的录制。事实上，这简直是“超临时”录制。我们本来可以直播的。史上最临时起意的录制。事实上，这简直是超临时录制。我们现在……我们本来可以直播的。我是说，对啊，通常在这个时候，
I mean, a couple of times I've posted around noon, Easter standard time, but usually I post around 8 or 9 a.m. And we're recording this. It's what, 10, 10.30? 10 a.m., a.m. Because if it was p.m., I would be asleep. This is true, yes.
我是说，有几次我是在东部标准时间中午左右发布的，但通常我都是在早上 8 点或 9 点左右发布。而我们现在在录音。几点了，10点，10点半？上午 10 点，上午。因为如果是下午的话，我早就睡着了。确实如此，没错。
Because we recorded last night, and as we are veterans, and we are now at episode 50, Bryce's audio was completely garbled. And so even though the content was gold, it was fire, we had to throw it in the trash. Yeah, it was a really good episode and really good content. And I'm sad that it got lost. I don't know what happened. When I started recording, I noticed that my levels were like really high. And I just thought, well, that's just me being normally loud. And then I was like sitting in my chair in an awkward way as I often do. But I didn't really think much of it. But I must have hit some control somewhere in Audacity, which is the software we use
因为我们昨晚录过一次了，而且作为老手，我们现在已经录到第 50 期了，布莱斯的音频却完全失真了。所以，尽管内容堪称黄金，非常精彩，我们还是不得不把它扔进垃圾桶。对，那期节目真的很棒，内容也很好。我很难过它丢了。我不知道怎么回事。我开始录音时，注意到我的音量级别非常高。我当时只觉得，嗯，那只是我平时声音比较大而已。然后我就像往常一样，以一个别扭的姿势坐在椅子上。但我真的没多想。不过我肯定在 Audacity 里不小心碰到了什么控制项，这就是我们用来
to record things that mess stuff up. But it seems fine this morning. So yeah. I thought about whether we should make this a live episode. I got up at 5 a.m. as I do these days, and I was like, I could tweet about it right now. And then I was like, yeah, but that's probably not a great thing to spring on, Connor. Yeah. Also, we would not have been able to talk about all of the stuff that we had to cut out of the beginning.
录制音频的软件，结果把事情搞砸了。不过今天早上看起来挺正常的。所以，对的。我考虑过我们是否应该把这期做成直播节目。我像最近一样早上 5 点起床，当时我就想，我可以直接发条推特。然后我又想，嗯，不过这事突然抛给康纳，可能不太好。对。另外，我们也无法聊那些不得不从开头剪掉的内容了。
Yeah. It's good times, man. The behind the scenes of ADSP, it's, uh, you guys got a little taste. That's the thing is you don't listen to the podcast price, but at the tail end of part two of the Dave Abrahams, I put a little bit of the bonus footage, like after we had said, Oh, we're done recording. Um, but then we were, you know, uh, just, uh, what's the word? Not waxing lyrical, but just, we, I was very excited about the whole APL breaking into Princeton. And then we were chatting about it.
没错，兄弟，真是好时光。ADSP 的幕后花絮，就是……你们稍微体验了一下。这就是问题所在，布莱斯，你平时不听播客，但在戴夫·亚伯拉罕（Dave Abrahams）访谈第二集的末尾，我放了一点点彩蛋片段，也就是在我们说“哦，录制结束了”之后，但然后，你知道的，我们只是……呃，用什么词来着？不是在抒情高歌，只是……我当时对 APL 闯入普林斯顿大学一事感到非常兴奋。然后我们就开始闲聊。
So, you know, we're starting to put some behind the scenes stuff. But yeah, there's other stuff that we can't say. And it's anyways, we're just teasing the listener. Let's try and combine. Well, we'll see. We'll see how far we get. So there's four things. So actually, there's a small silver lining in having to rerecord because I did forget about one of the things.
所以，你知道的，我们开始放一些幕后花絮了。不过，对啦，还有其他一些不能播的话合。不管怎样，我们只是在吊听众的胃口。让我们试着合并一下。好吧，我们走着瞧。看看我们能聊多远。所以有四件事。其实，不得不重新录制还有一个小小的安慰，那就是我确实忘了一件事。
But there's four things. This will definitely be higher quality because now I'm prepared. I've rehearsed all of my points. I have my tabs open. I have my research. We'll see, though, because we're going to try and keep this episode 30 minutes. And we'll start, though, today with what we finished with last time, which is, so this is episode 50. If you're a longtime listener, you'll know from a few episodes ago that I said every 50 episodes,
但有四件事。这次质量绝对会更高，因为现在我已经准备好了。我排练了我所有的论点。我打开了标签页。我做好了研究。不过，我们走着瞧，因为我们打算把这期节目控制在 30 分钟以内。不过今天我们要从上次结束的地方开始，也就是——所以这是第 50 期节目。如果你是老听众，你就会从几期前的节目中知道，我曾说过每 50 期节目，
we're going to plug our socials. And so yeah, ADSP, the podcast on Twitter, we just crossed a thousand followers. Thanks for following. Feel free to tweet at us there. I just passed 4,000 followers to which last night you said what, Bryce? You said that's... That's cute. That's cute. It's nice. I'm code underscore report. And Bryce, would you like to... I'm not sure how much enthusiasm are you going to be able to bring
我们就会宣传一下我们的社交账号。所以，对，Twitter 上的 ADSP 播客，我们刚刚突破了一千名粉丝。感谢关注。欢迎随时在那里@我们。我刚刚突破了 4,000 名粉丝，对此你昨晚说什么来着，布莱斯？你说这……太可爱了。这很可爱。挺不错的。我是 @code_underscore_report。布莱斯，你想……我不知道你现在还能保持多少热情
to the story now that it's part two or it's the second time around. No, no, no. I still have the enthusiasm. Don't worry. I have endless enthusiasm for this topic. I... I have passed 10 for this topic. I have passed 10,000 Twitter followers, but more importantly, I have more Twitter followers than JF. And why is this more important?
来讲述这个故事，毕竟这已经是第二部分了，或者说是重来一遍了。不，不，不。我依然充满热情。别担心。我对这个话题有着无尽的热情。我……在这个话题上，我已经超越了 10。我已经突破了 1 万名 Twitter 粉丝，但更重要的是，我的 Twitter 粉丝比 JF 多。为什么这更重要？
Because one, JF is the person who badgered me into joining Twitter or coming in and actively participating in Twitter, as he did for most of the C++ committee. Like JF like created C++ Twitter for anybody who doesn't know. So he brought me there and I came to Twitter after him, but now I have more followers because I clearly am just far more likable and charismatic and good looking and all these other things than JF. Yeah. And I actually passed him over the summer, but I knew I couldn't say anything about it immediately because if I did, Hana and JF would immediately organize
因为第一，JF 是那个软磨硬泡让我加入 Twitter、或者说进来积极参与 Twitter 的人，他对 C++ 委员会的大多数人也是这样。就像 JF 为所有不知道的人创建了 C++ Twitter 一样。所以是他把我带到那里的，我比他晚加入 Twitter，但现在我的粉丝比他多，因为我显然比 JF 更有好感度、更有魅力、长得更好看，还有其他各种优点。对。其实我在夏天就超过他了，但我知道我不能马上说出来，因为如果我说了，汉娜（Hana）和 JF 会立刻组织
some sort of campaign to unfollow Bryce to deflate my very, very oversized ego. And they would have been completely justified in doing so. But I was like, no, I need to be far enough ahead of him that when I tweet about it, it is challenging for him to reverse the situation. And so like there were, you know, at one point I was as many as like 200
某种取消关注布莱斯的活动，来打击我非常非常膨胀的自我。而且他们这样做完全是理所当然的。但我当时想，不，我得把他甩得足够远，当我发推特说这事时，他想扭转局面就很有难度了。所以当时有……你知道的，有一段时间我甚至比他多两百
or 300 followers ahead of him. And then like, you know, he'd tweet something great because like he's much better at tweeting than me. I don't know why I have more followers than him. Like he's way funnier, much better content. But, you know, he'd post something really good and then like he'd catch up and then like, you know, I'd post something like, you know, pretty good.
或三百个粉丝。然后呢，你知道的，他会发一些很棒的东西，因为他发推特比我厉害得多。我不知道为什么我的粉丝比他多。他明明幽默得多，内容也精彩得多。但是，你知道的，他会发一些真的很棒的东西，然后他就追上来了，接着，你知道的，我会发一些……你知道的，还不错的东西。
And then like I'd pull ahead again. Um, so it was like back and forth, like there were points where he got like as close as like being under a hundred again. Um, but I was finally like, you know, okay, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna really, uh, you know, get really far out ahead of him. Uh, so I'm just gonna wait until I hit 10,000 before him. And then, you know, that'll be good enough. And I mean, I should mention this. This is a little unfair to JF because one, JF just moved internationally. And two, JF has two small children. So he does not have as much time to shitpost on Twitter as, you know, say I do. Although he does manage to get an impressive amount in. But yeah, I have more than 10,000 followers on Twitter and he does not. He does not. Not yet.
然后我就会再次领先。所以，这就像是拉锯战，有时候他的粉丝数又跟他缩短到一百以内了。但我最终还是觉得，好吧，我不会真的把他甩得太远，所以我要等到粉丝数超过他达到一万时再公布。然后呢，这就足够了。而且，我得提一下。这对 JF 有点不公平，因为第一，JF 刚刚国际搬家。第二，JF 有两个幼儿。所以他没有像我这样有那么多时间在 Twitter 上发废话（shitpost），尽管他还是设法发了相当惊人的数量。不过，是的，我在 Twitter 上有超过一万名粉丝，而他没有。他没有。还没有。
But you should go follow him. But only if you're like, you can only follow him if you're also following me. You have to follow both of us. Yeah. You haven't even said your handle. Oh, my handle is BLolback, at BLolback. All right. And also, too, I just realized we're doing a lot of inside baseball. So do you want to explain who JF Bastion is and who Hannah Dusakova are? I'm sure there's a Swift developer. How can I explain who JF is?
但你们应该去关注他。不过只有在你……你只能在也关注了我的前提下才能关注他。你必须我们俩都关注。对。你甚至还没说你的账号呢。哦，我的账号是 @BLolback，在 BLolback。好的。另外，我也突然意识到我们聊了很多圈内黑话。所以你想解释一下什么是 JF·巴斯蒂安（JF Bastion）以及什么是汉娜·杜萨科娃（Hannah Dusakova）吗？我确信这里有个 Swift 开发者。我怎么解释谁是 JF 呢？
So, Jay, I am the library evolution chair on the committee, on the C++ committee. And JF is the language evolution chair. But our friendship goes back far longer than that. I've known him since about 2016 or so. When I first joined the committee, I became very good friends with JF and Olivier. I first came to the committee to mostly go to the concurrency and parallelism study group, which is where at the time they spent most of their time. And now you have to introduce who Olivier is. Yeah, I'm getting there, I'm getting there, I'm getting there.
所以，J……我是委员会上的库演进主席，在 C++ 委员会上。而 JF 是语言演进主席。但我们的友谊要比那长得多。我大约从 2016 年左右就认识他了。我刚加入委员会时，和 JF 以及奥利维耶（Olivier）成了很好的朋友。我最初来到委员会主要是为了参加并发与并行研究小组，当时他们大部分时间都在那里度过了。现在你得介绍一下奥利维耶是谁了。对，我这就说到，我这就说到，我这就说到。
And so the three of us sat in the back of the concurrency study group, which is called SG1 together. And we were just instantly thick as thieves. Now, Olivier and JF have known each other since they were in college, at least. They're both French Canadians. They both went to some of the same schools. And they had been on the committee together before me longer. But we were just like, we were a little band. And it's funny because at that time, we spent about a year or two where it was just the three of us. We were just regular committee members. And we spent most of our time in SG1. And now today, Olivier is the chair of SG1, the concurrency group. JF is the chair of the language evolution
于是我们三个人坐在并发研究小组（也就是 SG1）的后排，一见如故，亲密无间。现在，奥利维耶和 JF 至少在大学时就认识了。他们都是法裔加拿大人。他们都上过一些相同的学校。而且他们比我更早一起在委员会里。但我们就像是一个小团体。有趣的是，当时我们大约有一两年时间，只有我们三个。我们只是普通的委员会成员。我们把大部分时间都花在 SG1 上。而如今，奥利维耶是 SG1（并发小组）的主席，JF 是语言演进
group. And I am the chair of the library evolution group. And so we never actually spend time together on the committee anymore. And I, you know, Olivier works at NVIDIA. I also work at NVIDIA. He's one of the reasons why I came and worked at NVIDIA. And JF is, he's just, he's like a bad dad joke generator. And he's like very hipster, very hipster, I'm going to say. Yes, and the jokes are very bad and they are incessant. It is hard to have a conversation with JF without him just speaking in puns. And it's like, hey, you want to have a mentorship meeting? And he's like, sure.
小组的主席，而我是库演进小组的主席。所以我们在委员会里再也没有一起共事过了。而且，你知道的，奥利维耶在 NVIDIA 工作。我也在 NVIDIA 工作。他是让我来 NVIDIA 工作的原动力之一。至于 JF，他简直就是一个糟糕的爸爸笑话生成器。而且他非常嬉皮士，非常嬉皮士，我要这么说。是的，那些笑话非常糟糕，而且没完没了。跟 JF 说话很难不让他满嘴双关语。就像是：“嘿，你想开个导师会议吗？”他就会说：“当然。”
And you'll get three seconds in, and it's like, okay. But no, he... Meeting JF and Olivier at my first committee meeting, you know, a large, I think I can attribute a large part of my success in the committee to the friendships that I formed with them at my first few meetings. Yeah. And Hannah, you have to introduce her as well. Oh yeah, Hannah Nusikova, one of my closest friends who I
你刚聊三秒钟，就会觉得：好吧。不过说真的……在我的第一次委员会会议上结识 JF 和 Olivier，你知道的，我认为我在委员会取得的大部分成功都要归功于我在前几次会议上与他们建立的友谊。对。还有 Hannah，你也得介绍一下她。哦对，Hannah Dusakova，我最要好的朋友之一，我
when did I meet Hannah? Oh god, I'm going to get in trouble because I'm going to potentially get it wrong. But I think it was CPPCon 2018. Yeah, but she came and she gave this lightning talk about her compile time regular expression engine. And I had been watching the lightning talks and I don't want to offend anybody who gave a lightning talk that year, but it was like her lightning talk was so good. And not only was the talk very good, but the technology she was showing the library was so good that it was like the, like I saw it and I was like,
我是什么时候认识 Hannah 的呢？哦天哪，我要惹麻烦了，因为我可能会记错。但我认为是 CppCon 2018。对，她来做了一个关于她的编译期正则表达式引擎的闪电演讲。我一直在看闪电演讲，我不想冒犯那年做闪电演讲的任何人，但她的闪电演讲实在是太棒了。不仅演讲非常精彩，她展示的技术、那个库也太棒了，以至于我一看到就觉得，
wow, this is like, you know, this was the one thing that I paid attention to. Like I, before, before her talk, I was like, you know, messing around on my laptop, you know, multitasking, doing three things. I wasn't really paying attention, but then like she gave her talk and I was like, all right, laptop goes away. I'm paying attention right now. And it's funny because the way that, that her and I became friends is very similar to how you and I became friends. That, um, I saw both of you giving a talk. And then I knew at the end of that talk that we were going to be friends and that I was going to convince you to go and give a whole lot more talks because you were this first-time speaker, both of you, who was incredibly gifted.
哇，这简直是……你知道的，这是我唯一关注的东西。就像，在她的演讲之前，我在笔记本电脑上瞎搞，你知道的，一心多用，同时做三件事。我其实没怎么注意听。但后来她开始演讲，我就想：好吧，笔记本电脑收起来。我现在要认真听了。有趣的是，我和她成为朋友的方式，跟你和我成为朋友的方式非常相似。我看到你们俩都在做演讲。在那场演讲结束时，我就知道我们会成为朋友，而且我要说服你们去做更多的演讲，因为你们俩都是极具天赋的初次演讲者。
And I could see that, but maybe you hadn't, you know, recognized that yet. But so, yeah, so I encouraged her to give a full talk. Maybe it was next year at CppCon, or maybe it was at C++ Now, but she's going on to give a number of incredibly impressive talks. And the way that she builds her slide decks are just, they are, it makes me feel bad about how I build my slide decks. Hers are just so good. So polished. And this is coming from, like, I consider,
我能看出这一点，但也许你们当时还没意识到这一点。所以，是的，我鼓励她做一个完整的演讲。也许是第二年在 CppCon 上，或者是在 C++ Now 上，但她接着发表了许多极其精彩的演讲。她制作幻灯片的方式简直……这让我对如何制作幻灯片感到很惭愧。她的幻灯片实在是太棒了。太精致了。而且这是出于——我觉得，
like Bryce and I, we share a lot in common, but we love beautiful slideware. And yeah, Hanna Dusakova's, like her finite automata talk, where she had the, I think it was, she said it was, I can't remember. I'm going to get it wrong. But it was thousands of lines of JavaScript to generate these very smooth animations of the finite diagrams, like morphing from one to another. It was one of the most beautiful things. The best way to describe it is that the quality of Hana's presentations is what you would expect from a curated professional presentation
就像我和 Bryce 有很多共同点，但我们都热爱精美的幻灯片。是的，Hana Dusakova 的演讲，比如她的有限自动机演讲，她拥有……我想她说过，我不记得了。我可能会记错。但那是数千行 JavaScript 代码，用来生成这些非常流畅的有限图表动画，从一个形态平滑变幻到另一个形态。这是最美丽的景象之一。形容 Hana 演讲质量最好的方式，就是它达到了你对一个由团队为某个重大活动精心筹备的专业演示文稿的预期。
that was prepared by a team for some like major event. Like, you know, the quality of a TED talk, I think even probably beyond that, or like the quality of like a talk that a CEO was giving to announce some new product where like a year has been spent preparing this talk. And there was like a team of like 10 designers that built the slide deck and like everything was you know carefully curated and reviewed um yeah it's just um it's really next level it's not comparable to any of the other um talks that i've seen at any of the c++ conferences or tech conferences in general um because she essentially, she built this whole platform for her to give these talks. And she built this whole platform
比如，TED 演讲的质量，甚至可能超越那个水平，或者像是 CEO 为了发布某个新产品而花费整整一年时间准备的演讲的质量。那里有一个由 10 名设计师组成的团队来制作幻灯片，所有东西都经过精心策划和审查……是的，这真的是提升到了一个新的水平，无法与我在任何 C++ 会议或一般技术会议上看到的任何其他演讲相媲美……因为她基本上为自己的演讲建立了一整套平台。她建立了一整套平台，
for how to visualize, you know, how regular expression engines work. And it's just, even if you don't know C++, it's worth watching her talk. You'll definitely learn something about regex from it. But yeah, it's just, it's really something else.
用来可视化正则表达式引擎是如何工作的。即使你不懂 C++，看她的演讲也很值得。你绝对能从中学到一些关于正则的知识。不过，是的，这真的是别具一格。
Yeah. Yeah. And also she is now the chair of SG, I'm not gonna remember the number, right? Compile time? The seven, I want to say, the Reflection and Metaprogramming Study Group. Yes, she is chair of that study group the on the c++ committee all right well that was uh that was 20 minutes of twitter so now i think we're going to just spend the next 10 minutes on the last three things that i said and we'll have to we'll have to record our actual content episode um i don't know a different time so what was um
对。是的。而且她现在是 SG 的主席，我记不清编号了，对吧？编译期？第七小组，我想是，反射与元编程研究小组。是的，她是 C++ 委员会中那个研究小组的主席。好吧，那是 20 分钟的 Twitter 闲聊，现在我想我们大概要花接下来的 10 分钟来聊我刚才说的最后三件事，然后我们还得在不同的时间重新录制我们的实际内容节目……我不知道。那么，
the other well so the the fourth thing that I forgot to mention last time when we recorded is that CPP North has a survey out that I'll link in the show notes that people should go and fill out. Just like asking, you know, are you interested in going to the conference? It's like, I don't know, two minute survey. It's got like five questions in it. If you are thinking about going or, you know, have responses to that, I'm sure the committee would be thrilled, uh, to get your feedback. That was number four. Um, oh yeah. And then the third thing was that, uh, do we want to talk about that? The right scan, left scan, um, now we should, we should try to squeeze in, we should try
另外……第四件事是我上次录音时忘记提到了，就是 CPP North 有一份调查问卷出炉了，我会把它链接在节目文案中，大家可以去填写。它只是询问，你知道的，你对去参加会议感兴趣吗？大概是一个两分钟的调查。里面有五个问题。如果你正在考虑去参加，或者对会议有反馈意见，我相信委员会一定会非常高兴听到你的意见。那是第四点。哦对了。然后第三点是，我们想聊聊那个吗？右扫描（right scan）、左扫描（left scan）……现在我们应该尝试把效率问题塞进去。哦，我们该那么做吗？好吧，你能在类似……我们在
to squeeze in the efficiency. Oh, should we do that? Well, so can you do it in like, we're try to squeeze in the efficiency. Oh, should we do that? Well, so can you do it in like, we're at 20 minutes now. So can you do it in like 10 minutes? I got it polished. So we did Twitter announcements and we did a survey announcement. We'll get to the two other things at some future episode. Now, listener, strap in for Bryce's explanation of the difference between efficiency and speed.
20 分钟了。所以你能在 10 分钟内讲完吗？我把它打磨好了。所以我们做了 Twitter 公告和调查公告。我们会在将来的某期节目中讨论另外两件事。现在，听众朋友们，系好安全带，听 Bryce 解释效率和速度的区别。
And more importantly, I think you nailed it, Bryce. 10 minutes. Yeah, although I gotta go get dressed and then run to my thing. So that was what I'm going to do is this is going to be split into two episodes. Now, Bryce, you just heard Bryce said that, said that oh yeah i can do it in 10 minutes and it ended up taking 32 minutes uh and uh because this is now a part of episode part one of this recording um we forgot we totally asked people to go follow us on our socials and we totally forgot you have to this is the once every 50 episodes where we're allowed to ask people to go and leave a review if you want so bryce would you like to ask the listener anything you'd like to say to them? Go and leave us a review on Apple Podcasts.
更重要的是，我觉得你抓住了要领，Bryce。10分钟。对，虽然我得去穿衣服，然后赶去我的事情那儿。所以我要做的是，这期节目将拆分成两个部分。现在，Bryce，你刚才听到 Bryce 说，说“哦对，我能在 10 分钟内讲完”，结果花了 32 分钟……而且……因为这现在成了本次录音第一部分的内容，我们忘了，我们完全忘了让大家去关注我们的社交账号，我们完全忘了——这是每 50 期才有一次的机会，我们可以让大家去留个评价，如果你愿意的话——所以 Bryce，你想对听众提什么要求吗？有什么想对他们说的吗？去 Apple Podcasts 上给我们留个评价吧。
At least I assume that that's what we're supposed to do because that's what all the other podcasts tell me to do. That's not even what we're supposed to say. If you want to. Oh, if you want to. If you want to. You don't have to. We're not even imploring you.
至少我以为我们应该这么说，因为其他所有播客都这么教我。这甚至不是我们该说的话。如果你愿意的话。哦，如果你愿意的话。如果你愿意的话。你不用非得这么做。我们甚至都没有在恳求你。
I don't use to you know we're not even imploring you yeah i don't i don't use apple podcasts um didn't we say we were going to do an episode where we found these reviews and like we read them uh because neither of us have actually um have looked into them but we promise if you do go leave a review we'll find it in a future episode uh maybe episode 100 that's what we'll do what are you laughing about buddy i'm laughing because i really i really am gonna have to go because i'm gonna i'm gonna be late well that's not on me if that's on your 10 minute explanation no i'm gonna blame i'm gonna blame you i'm gonna blame you okay that's fine if i'm late thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不用……你知道的，我们甚至都没有在恳求你。对，我不用……我不用 Apple Podcasts……我们不是说要做一期节目去寻找这些评价并朗读它们吗？因为我们俩实际上都……都没有去查过。但我们保证，如果你去留个评价，我们会在以后的节目中找到它——也许在第 100 期节目里，我们就这么办。你在笑什么呢，老兄？我在笑是因为我真的……我真的得走了，因为我要……我要迟到了。好吧，这可不能怪我，要怪你那 10 分钟的解释。不，我要怪你。我要怪你。好吧，没关系，如果我迟到了的话。谢谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天！ 本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。